[Musique]
je suis vraiment désolé
on est là pour sauver la vie de notre
ami et rien d'autre
on a payé pour nous faire rentrer ici et
sortir d'ici elle aurait dû dire oh je
vais le faire discrètement personne ne
saura quand je l'ai fait mais non madame
préfère tirer sur tout le monde et
menacer des innocents
et vous devez sûrement vous demander
pourquoi je me suis fié à elle ça c'est
une bonne question et la réponse c'est
qu'avant elle et moi on s'aimait c'était
ma petite amie ok elle s'en souvient pas
parce qu'elle était une autre son père
l'a balancé d'une falaise magique elle
s'est tuée j'ai pété un plomb et j'ai
failli détruire l'univers et la voilà
elle est revenue d'un lointain passer et
oui c'était dans ce passé tout le monde
est bord et elle non peut-être grâce à
la magie de la falaise ça j'en sais rien
parce que je suis pas un spécialiste des
pierres d'infinité
rien qui a rencontré une fille en or qui
est tombée amoureux mais cette fille est
morte et elle vient de revenir
totalement taré
il a oublié quelques infos importantes
mais
il a résumé l'essentiel